[Music]
hey on today's show we're going to talk
to a mom who keeps comparing herself to
other moms
we're going to talk about what to do
when your in-laws are conspiracy
theorists
we're going to talk about building
strong accountable friendships
for men and women we all need them stay
[Music]
tuned hey what's up what's up this is
john with the dr
john dolone show and i never
had to knock on wood but i know someone
who has
remember that song makes me wonder if i
could
man brendan hurston got me into ska
music back when i was in high school
dude that's
so good never love it man hey so hey
we're so glad that you're with us
we're talking about mental health
relationships
work anything you can imagine we're
talking about on this show i'm so glad
you're here
hey we have crossed the mill we are
our best month again um in our in our
production meeting the other day
um the numbers guys the zeros and ones
guys said man it's just becoming a
broken record we keep breaking records
after records every month after month so
thank you so so much for joining us and
for walking alongside us
a couple of cool things number one nude
my favorite band of all time
social distortion they just celebrated
their 40-year anniversary
and i guess it's i don't know who
one of the board members blake here is a
music aficionado
and sociald did a partnership with
madison sunglasses
the sunglasses i buy are usually five
dollars at home depot
and these are fancy pants man and he
gave him to me as a gift
fancy uh uh
sunglasses and social d on my face
on my big giant square head man shout
out to blake thanks for making my dreams
come true
and james this is a big moment for the
show
somebody reached out on the interwebs to
me talking some
trash and it was something along the
lines of
both you and james are idiots because
they said
fender idiot gibson idiots
and he posted this picture of this all
white and gold
gretch like these giant for those of you
it's inside baseball and guitar nerds
but it's this big
hollow body or hollow body dramatic
guitar for billionaires to play with
horn sections
like brian setzer for folks who
man who think you know what i can't get
my truck lifted
because i'm just not that kind of person
and i don't want to lower my honda civic
i'm going to get aggressed that'll show
them right i think that
i think we just found a common enemy
that can unite us i think i think from
this point forward
you and i are united you will wheel up
your
stratocaster and you're rolling
jazzmaster and i will bring my
gibson les paul i mean my gibson and
marshall
and he'll bring his 30-piece horn
section
and uh his low self-esteem and he'll
play some wiggly deedly dee
pretty sure fender owns gretch by the
way not just the company oh but also
pejoratively
internet burn i don't even know what all
that means but i i would thumbs down you
if i had the ability to do that
so how do you like them apples james i
like to see this show brings people
together including you and me
you and me we found a common enemy
bring it gretch next thing we know we're
going to get some paul reed smith guy
saying but my guitar is the best just
look at creed and then
then the show will we'll have one the
internets will be over
it'll be awesome so hey if you want to
challenge me and james to your
fancy guitar off you'll probably win
because i'm not that good but james is a
really great player
so i challenge you to bring it all right
let's go straight to the phones let's go
to
i always say let's go straight to the
phones after meandering around for a
while
now let's go to the phones let's go to
ashley in boston hey ashley what's going
on
hi dr john how are you i'm so good how
about you
i'm doing all right i'm a little nervous
i'm very excited to talk to you
i'm super nervous too and i'm excited to
talk to you also so
we can be nervous together let's figure
it out what's up
so um i've been listening to your show
for a while
and i really haven't heard this question
get
brought up um so i will just get right
into it
i am a mom of an eight-year-old daughter
and i have been married to my husband
for seven years um he also has two
children
who are not mine so we both have
children that we brought in
prior so we don't share any children
together
we've been together for seven years all
the kids have
grown up together both of his children
are actually
10 they're six months apart so they're
from two different moms
um my daughter is also like i said from
a different dad
um and over the past seven years we've
really worked hard on trying to
basically create this family for when
we're together
um as normal as possible whatever normal
means
right whatever that means in 2021
right um and as the kids are getting
older
you know it's becoming i think just
with the way that things are so
different now and technology
and different temptations i mean growing
up as a kid is a lot different than even
when i grow up
right and i'm really struggling and my
husband and i are struggling
with the difference in households um
and kind of that transition period of
when we get my step kids back
we share like a week on week off
schedule with his kids
and you know the expectations
at the mom's households are a lot
different than ours yep
and it feels like you know we're kind of
more like
the rural household um we have
they have the party house in the twinkie
house and then the uh
fruits and vegetables house basically
yes
and fun ruiner ashley
and it's hard um because as a stepmom
um you know i'm not their biological
moms their moms are
completely in their life um and
you know we've had some really big ups
and downs with those relationships
with the relationships with those other
moms yes okay
um you know we've gone through some
legal stuff with a different mom we've
done
just different things and and you know i
have a pretty good relationship
with my stepson's mother i think better
than my step-daughter's mom
and it's caused a lot of strain i think
on my relationship
with the kids and trying to navigate
not resenting the kids for their moms or
not
comparing myself constantly to the other
moms
yeah i was gonna ask you why do you why
do you compare yourself to those moms
um because
i guess i'm always second guessing if
i'm doing it right if
you know because i'm not their
biological mom so every parent on planet
earth 100 of the time
second guesses whether they're doing it
right or not and those that don't
second-guess
are usually insane like they
have this like this is the way to do it
and then those kids keep the
mental health association of america
afloat there's not a mental health
association but they keep all the
psychologists and family therapists
afloat for the next generation um
yeah comparison is is i mean you know
this that it just steals
your soul from you right um very much so
but usually when i can when i am
comparing myself to something
it's because a i'm not totally secure in
what i'm doing right whether it's like
about
exercise or diets or whatever i think i
haven't fully done the work to know
right where i stand on my values and
what i believe
and then um the other part is
this insecurity as though i have this
imaginary standard i'm trying to live
into some fantasy that doesn't exist
does that make sense yes
and i guess that's you know this is my
first time being stepmom
i've been doing it for seven years so
are you doing a good job i'm
trying to no are you doing a good job
i think so try again are you doing a
good job
yes yes you are and so
yeah um you
y'all have just uh a fun
sound and i'm saying fun because i like
chaos that's just a thing i love
so you guys have a fun household right
you've got
three three was it three moms two dads
is that right yeah three moms two dads
and a merry-go-round
and y'all are trying not to get dizzy on
a merry-go-round and so that's always
gonna be hard and at the same time
you're gonna have more opportunity for
adventure and vomiting and laughter
does that make sense it's all of it
right
it is and i think that's what i'm
struggling with most now
is that i think this constant comparison
or i guess even second guessing like
does that time really matter they don't
have you know different bedtimes at mom
and dad's and
the transition period i think
longer now because it takes them a
couple days to like re-acclimate to
what we're doing or you know we have
chores and we have responsibilities and
you know extracurricular activities and
we always want the kids to be doing
different things but i you know some of
the other parents don't agree with that
and they don't share that same value
so then i start second guessing you know
which one's right and wrong and i feel
like
i'm more of like a military parent
almost like i'm
constantly worried about everything kind
of being perfect so that our
chaos isn't so crazy but then so
you're not going to do this perfectly
you're not
my two kids me and their mom
are stable and that's the yellow aren't
stable you know
it's there's not all this chaos there's
not coming and going
and dude we're screwing it up right so
you're not gonna do it perfectly
one of the big challenges um
in blended families is a the fantasy
that we're going to make this just like
our fantasy about a regular family and
as you mentioned there's not really a
regular family it's not that's not a
thing
it's just kind of it's a sometimes a
media fabrication right
and then on top of the quote-unquote
regular family
um the wife
the stepmom often is the one tasked with
pulling all these strings to make sure
this thing looks the way the fantasy
supposed to look
that makes sense yes and
so my challenge to you is
is to absolutely let that go
because here's what's going to happen
having boundaries
is going to be annoying for any teenager
in any home
in of any shape size whatever
boundaries are hard especially for kids
they are wired to bang their heads up
against those boundaries
now and when they're toggling back and
forth week
off week on week off week on it's even
harder i'm not a huge fan of the week on
week off for this very reason it's hard
for a child to toggle back and forth
in a 14 15 11 12 those are children
right
um your values are your values and as
long as you're continuing to get wisdom
not from a comparison but from people
that you trust
and as long as you and your husband are
communicating with each other
you don't have to apologize for your
values you don't have to apologize for
your expectations for the kids when
they're in your home you just don't
and you have to expect that they're not
going to like it
and your goal right now isn't for them
to like you
their goal what you're doing is raising
great grown-ups
great adults and my promise is if you
play a long game here
they will circle back and over time pick
up you'll see them adopt those things
into their life that you're teaching
so it feels militant to you it's
probably not
right it's probably not i think the
other thing that i'm struggling with too
is maybe because me and the other moms
don't share the same values or the same
expectations i think sometimes for the
kids that i
tend to resent them or feel like well
why don't they care about the kids as
much as i do
or and that's hey that's a that's you
trying to
wallpaper over shame yeah
it's not real and listen all that's
going to get you
is this a kinetic tension when the kids
are in your presence
and they're going to start stepping away
from you not because your boundaries but
because you're a third rail
and you're going to start asking those
questions hey well what about
and how about and they're going to hear
you grumbling they're going to see you
roll your eyes
and then suddenly you're going to put
them in a position to
have to choose between this woman who my
dad loves so we clearly like her
or we pretend we don't but we do she
makes us safe she's got hard boundaries
but she
kind of doesn't approve of our moms and
i'm gonna choose my mom
every time because i'm a child right
right
right absolutely right don't put
a child in a position to choose don't do
that
be really proud of the values you and
your husband have agreed on that's
awesome
be really firm in how much you love love
love those kids
never ever ever talk bad about their
their parents
their their birth moms and if you've got
to grit your teeth if you've got to go
talk to a counselor you need to go for a
walk then do that
but i'll tell you asking questions like
why don't they love as much as
i guarantee you those moms are saying
good luck why can't they just
this woman just let my child have a good
time
why could they just finish the movie on
a school night for crying out loud why
can't they just get a cell phone for
right and so those things become
circular they're a
waste of your life and at some point
somebody told you that what the what you
believed what you think
wasn't good whether that was your
ex-husband whether that was your family
whether that was
wherever that came from then i hate that
for you
because your values are good they're
your values
right yeah and as long as they're
tethered to things that are
good and you know um
strong and they're in relationship with
other people man those are your values
so let me ask you this question what's
one thing you need to improve
and here's why i asked that um i
often do okay i i often
go compare go go on a comparison hunt
when i know i'm not doing what i'm
supposed to be doing
right i really get obsessive about other
people's workout programs when i've just
laid off for two weeks
i get really critical of the way
somebody looks in their shirt
or the way somebody's eating at lunch
when i've let my diet go
to crap right so i'll ask you
what's something that's surfaced over
the last year
that you're really getting
self-conscious about that's making you
go on
on the hunt for what other people are
doing wrong in their lives
um i think people said patience tell me
about that
and i mean
i think being a working mom on top of
any of it and you come home and
everything's crazy and you're just
trying to get tasks done
and when things go out of that and um
you know i i tend to use my patients and
i don't feel like i give the kids enough
of my attention when it's that time
and i know i've heard you talk about
that about dedicating
certain times you know you wear
different hats at different times and
um you know i think i'm just not
enjoying
everything feels like a task and i think
that's
you know part of this parenting journey
but it's
it's not fun anymore you know like even
when you
go to do stuff or it just always feels
like
everything's being complete or say i
mean just for instance say we're gonna
go
take the kids to the zoo and on the ride
up there one of them might talk about
the time they went to the zoo with their
mom and that's all they're talking about
the entire time
so that's what i mean by it never feels
good enough sometimes that no matter
what gift no matter what i say no matter
what i do
it's and i think the kids do that
automatically just because they're kids
and you want to talk about
fun things you did with your friends so
here's something important for you to
know i love that you just told me that
so number one
you just called yourself out right this
isn't fun anymore
this is hard running a blended family
managing all these different parents
trying to love
two ten-year-olds and a seven-year-old
is chaos
in the best of circumstances right
not to mention a messy circumstance like
you guys have okay
exhale through that you're in a season
it's like
it's like you walked outside in the
middle of winter and you just think i'm
going to freeze to death because this is
never going to warm up i promise it is
okay a great thing you can do for
yourself is to begin to think i'm going
to default to relationships not tasks
what's the silliest thing we can do
right now or hey everybody in the house
i just got home from work
we're gonna have 15 minutes i'm gonna
bomb everybody with water balloons or
everybody we're gonna do 15 minutes
everybody clean up and then we're gonna
go do something
it's not fun for you it's not rest for
you but it is default to relationship
and my promise is on the back end of
that
you will feel better than coming home
and trying to
like crack a whip get everybody to do
their task make sure everything's
checked off and everything looks the way
it's supposed to quote unquote look
the second thing is is that very common
in blended families is this pressure
a ten-year-old feels to not
abandon mom to not abandon dad wherever
they happen to be
and so when they go to the zoo with you
there is a part of them that is feels
like they are abandoning their birth mom
and so they have to surface that they
got to bring that up
so that they can let themselves know i
still value her
even though i feel really safe with this
new woman ashley
even though i feel really excited to go
with her to the zoo
oh i want to make sure i'm not letting
go of mom
that makes sense that has nothing to do
with you and everything to do with a 10
year old feeling like their world's
coming apart
yeah and that's i think where i'm
struggling where i feel like i'm
having feelings towards the kids even
though i love them but it's
this constant like comparison
listen listen do you love those kids do
you love those kids
yes a lot i do
okay i believe you and so when you hear
them
talk about their birth moms the most
loving thing you can do is to say
you are so lucky to have a mom
that will take you to the zoo
you've got two moms taking you to the
zoo
the luckiest kid ever right
tell me about what you you and your mom
like to do at the zoo
lean into it and you completely let go
of that comparison
and if it drives you i want you not to
write a fence on this i want you to lean
completely into it if you say hey
everybody it's eight o'clock it's
bedtime and one of them says
my mom lets me stay up till 9. i want
you to say
all right in our house we've talked
about this i want you to go get in bed
at eight and then when i want you to go
sit by them
when you're gonna read them a bedtime
story because it's good to read the kids
and say tell me about a nine o'clock
bedtime what's that like in your mom's
house
lean all the way into it right lean all
the way into it
don't make a kid choose between who
they're going to love
let them know that both of them both
moms love them
a lot and expect it those conversations
those comparisons are not about you
they're about the kid
feeling like they're having to choose
and they're coming apart
right and you
look at the world that you're feeling
less than where are you
feeling shame where do you feel like
some of your relational stuff is in ash
right are you really busy at work and
you're coming home and your kids are
getting your second or third fruits
is your husband not participating in
some of this stuff you need to get his
lazy butt in there to help is there some
places where you have
in moments when things start rattling
you default to tasks and i wanted to
look this way
versus you know what i don't give a crap
we'll do the dishes tomorrow hey husband
you get your butt in here and do the
dishes
we're gonna go outside and throw grass
at each i don't know what you're going
to do we're going outside kick soccer
ball around
because i'm going to default to
relationships first i think we've got
and we've got an obsession with our
kitchen's got to look this way
our house has to look this way i gotta
finish these emails i've got i've got
i've gotta
and we're waiting till all these tasks
are done before we do relationship
and the tasks never get done which means
we never do relationship
and then we go comparison hunting and
then these things just turn into ash
they just melt right ashley i
love your question i love your heart the
answer's inside you
and i am super excited to hear what
happens when you transition to some of
these new
new ways of doing things default
relationships over tasks
and start leaning really into those
those comparisons
lean way into them and see if your kids
don't
exhale you become a safe space they can
talk about
how cool their other mom is their other
house is
you become a safeway and i know it's
hard if you need to find someone to talk
to find someone to talk to
don't let comparison steal your soul all
right let's go to
mike in green bay hey mike what's up man
hey dr dolani thanks for uh taking my
call here you got man what's up
my in-laws are into online conspiracy
theories
and my wife had a hey i just i just lost
you come back one more time
your in-laws are into online conspiracy
theories
yes okay tell me about it
um i love those yeah
it's it's kind of everything it's the
election it's vaccines it's monetary
system
child sex trafficking everything all in
one
my wife had a boundary conversation with
them i went
very poorly okay and we kind of patch it
up a little bit but it's extremely
awkward talking to them my wife is
struggling because she doesn't
know who to talk to without making her
parents sound crazy
and uh you know we're trying to figure
out how to move forward with the
relationship
how did the boundary conversation go
like i don't i don't want you all to
talk about this stuff anymore
with me i'm tired of hearing it like
what what how did it go yeah
um they'd started emailing stuff out to
us and extended family
um and usually what they emailed wasn't
terrible but the problem was the next
video
claimed that everybody was vaccinated
was going to die and they sent it to
people who were vaccinated hey here's
the thing that's true about that
everyone who got got vaccinated will
eventually die that's super true
i don't know what your problem is mike
but listen
everybody who got a vaccine is one day
gonna be dead
i think it was a two years claim in
there that was the problem oh okay
well fair enough all right um so it was
basically
we don't want you to talk to us about
this we we don't find these sources
credible
if you want to send something it's got
to be credible and don't talk to our
kids or we're not going to you know this
will be a deal breaker
yep and so they took it as an attack on
their beliefs which it
i guess kind of was yeah and plus i
think just
freaked out about uh essentially saying
uh you're not gonna see your grandkids
if you don't stop
and so it went awkward
they said you're attacking our beliefs
and
so you guys put up a boundary and then
they crashed into it
and then what happened to that boundary
did y'all say okay you can email us
or do they say okay we'll quit um
i'd say it went way more than awkward it
went horrible but they have respected
the boundary
okay it's just now it's extremely
awkward to interact with them because
you really can't
share much of your life because of the
beliefs are kind of intertwined in
everything so you can't talk about
what's happening without a risk of
knocking into that
oh so you can't talk about like what's
going on in the world like i guess you
can't talk about health or politics or
medicine or anything because y'all are
such odds
yes okay and so how can i help
i guess we're trying to figure out do we
just keep moving
forward i mean it's kind of like there's
an elephant in the room do we need to
address it or we move forward
plus any advice on how my wife can get
help
because she really feels like she
doesn't have any anybody to talk to
because her parents aren't good people
of course and she doesn't want to bash
them in front of
friends or yeah yeah so that that
doesn't help anybody
um okay so let me back out a little bit
there was a remarkable article a while
ago we'll link to it in the show notes
from peter atia he's one of the most
brilliant minds on planet earth the guy
who i
have a lot of respect for um
he wrote um he's a statistician and a
medical doctor a longevity guy but he
wrote an awesome
article on conspiracy theories and he
had a couple of things in there
that gave me some
um more empathy than i've ever had
and so he talked about um these a lot of
big words but
talks about um some of the biases and
fallacies that attract people to
conspiracy theories
like selection bias and confirmation
bias in group bias and false cause black
or white fallacies and appeals to
emotion bandwagon
ambiguity except all the stuff right
burden of proof right all that kind of
stuff
um but then he goes on to say that often
conspiracy theories may be wired into us
for
survival purposes and so here here's
where he goes with that
a let's pretend ten thousand years ago
we're walking in the jungle
and a splash occurs next to us
more than likely that was a branch
falling from a tree
it was a rock it was filled any number
of things
but if we didn't jump and run
small chance that was an alligator we're
dead it's over
and so there's a part of us that may be
hardwired
to see any sort of as this could kill me
right any sort of glitch in the matrix
any sort of big splash a loud noise
we are better off running and hiding and
pointing
because that keeps us alive it makes us
insane
but it keeps us alive right so he says
that it's far more likely that it's
nothing but the price to pay for being
wrong can change our actions
even if the statistics are in our favor
right
so at the end of the day i think there's
two things about the conspiracy
and i'll tell you it's a sport for me i
think they're hilarious and
awesome like i but here's the thing i
don't believe them
but they are super fun for me i do have
several friends that not aren't all in
they are a
thousand percent in in the
most hilarious ways um i got co-workers
here who are
dude it is the most fun to have
conversations i feel like i'm on another
planet it's amazing
and um here's what i think it's about
number one i think it's about control
it is really hard for us to step back
and swallow the fact that a
volcano may erupt and just kill us all
it may be really hard for us to swallow
the fact that
and somebody on the other side of the co
on the other side of the world ate
something
and it spun up a virus or even scarier
that there was a lab working on
something
and it accidentally got on a couple of
guys and they just went to the store
and then the whole world shut down that
is so
terrifying because that proves to us we
don't control
anything and so the only thing we can do
is double down on
oh no no this is a giant plot by people
who know what they're doing to kill us
all does that make sense that's how i
have
i can't live in a world where lee harvey
oswald just some oddball climbed up in
the top
of a library and shot the president i
can't live in a world where a guy's that
good of a marksman
where all i have to live in a world
where there's this massive
huge conspiracy that covered all that up
because if that can happen
the world we are spinning on is on a
razor's edge at all times
right um this happened at the capitol
uh and on the january 6th thing when the
when those
guys try to take over the capital now i
don't get in the politics of all that
but what what blew my mind was i always
had this idea and i don't know what it
looked like but
that if you ever just tried to storm the
u.s capitol there was like lasers built
into the ground that just
zapped everybody i had i don't know what
i was thinking but i didn't know you
could do that
right i didn't know a group of people
could just run across the lawn and
climb the walls of the capitol i just
thought that like navy seals would fall
out of the clouds and
right and so either i have to believe
one of two things
oh crap that can happen like a group of
people could just get on the white house
lawn and charge
or that it was this big thing and that
there was you know all these things were
shut down and we had to does that make
sense
so living in a conspiracy world is
actually a safer world sometimes
because it adds order to a potentially
really chaotic existence
and here's the second thing that is also
on top of that
is that when we don't sleep
and we stay glued to these screens and
we are anxious and anxious and anxious
anxiety makes us meaning making machines
it spins us up and we get obsessed with
trying to connect dots almost like a
beautiful mind so we get to these
these feelings that we're having our
bodies alarms that are set off
and man we have all been so exhausted
and
frustrated and angry and scared over the
last year and it's just given me some
some real compassion for folks and dude
i've got them in my life i've got family
members i got co-workers
i know exactly what you're dealing with
so
here's the good news and the bad news
i'll give you the bad news first you
guys laid down a boundary and it's up to
y'all to hold it
and the promise of boundaries is that it
keeps you all safe it does not mean it
keeps you comfortable
it doesn't mean that it keeps you
friction free
and that's hard right
yep the other side of the good news is
you laid a boundary down and i'm proud
of you guys
what i think would be bold and brave if
they would do it and this is
the rare person that can do this would
be if you
and or your wife circled back and said
hey there's attention now
we just said we don't talk about this
stuff anymore and now i feel like we
can't talk about anything
and um i don't want to lose y'all's
relationship and at the same time these
things are hard for us to swallow
um how's the last month for y'all been
and listen to them and let them speak it
out loud does that make sense
not everybody can do that i know
a lot of times when boundaries get put
up people smash their heads up against
them they get angry they get
mad they kick and scream and all of a
sudden they think oh gosh someone
precious who i love is on the other side
of that boundary and i'm not going to
lose that
i may be crazy but i've seen that in my
own family i've seen that in my own
personal relationships that may be too
soon for you guys
um and you guys have to make peace with
it may this not happen
it may not happen i am interested in
this when you guys said hey we're not
going to have you
talk to our kids about this crap we're
not going to talk about this stuff
um what did they say you don't love your
children
how dare you like what was their
response
um no they actually they um
they agreed to that they respected it
they didn't uh
they didn't argue about that too much so
what where's the awkwardness coming from
is it now coming from you guys you all
laid down the law and you won
and now you guys don't know what to talk
about yes
uh so are there things you want to talk
to them about
well i mean the struggle is we have
public facing jobs where you have to
take over seriously we can't talk about
that
you can't talk about much work you
pretty much
you're down to talking about the weather
and
it's just like what do you all interact
with them a lot
uh yeah we used to daily
i mean they live a lot quite a ways away
um but we used to talk them daily
it's less frequent now and uh we used to
have a very close relationship with them
and i think that's probably the
loss there is hard yes i agree with that
so here's
two things i'm gonna throw out there man
you may roll your eyes and say this is
so cheesy
you can use me as the scapegoat just say
dude i've
we've got some knucklehead and he made
this recommendation i'd love it if y'all
would do this with us
they get to pick a book and you all get
to pick a book
and just say hey we want to read this
together y'all pick and we'll pick
um y'all are obviously wise and smart
you raised a really
smart and beautiful wonderful daughter
and
we want to start like a little family
nerd book club
that may be so cheesy and they may roll
their eyes they may be all in
and it becomes a place for y'all to
discuss things
and it doesn't it can be fiction it
doesn't have to be about anything
dramatic the other thing is man we had
some of the funniest most hilarious time
not talking about stuff with my parents
um especially during covenant we
couldn't visit they couldn't visit
was playing games on zoom they were
a riot playing charades on zoom playing
card game
man it turned into some of the most fun
um
even setting up you know i imagine you
guys could sit up to checkerboards with
the kids
whatever that looks like but see if
y'all can begin to do things together
maybe go visit with them and go fishing
spend some money that y'all probably
wouldn't hadn't planned on spending
go if you do some things like that that
y'all can get together i think that
would be really remarkable
and instead of focusing on talking about
stuff
issues man try to get back into
relational stuff
play games read stuff together
watch a movie with your wife and they
can watch it you know talk about it
find common ground that is not about
those things
it's going to be harder because you have
these default things politics
religion weather repeat and now you have
a chance to expand that portfolio of
things you all talk about
broaden this relationship heal it a
little bit then y'all get to decide you
want to keep your boundaries
they get to decide if they want to keep
your boundaries i'm proud of y'all and
i'm proud of them
sounds like everybody said whoa well
relationship's the most important thing
here
and now the balls in y'all's court to
come up with some new deeper ways to
connect with one another
right so thank you so much for that call
mike um i know that's hard dude i know
that's hard and i know families all over
the country are dealing with that
be creative and preserve those
relationships wherever possible
all right hey we'll be right back stay
with us
[Music]
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important
your mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy
for you video chat phone or even
text chat counseling with licensed
therapists
that are going to help you become a
better version of yourself
help you get on the road to being well
go to for betterhelp.com10 off
your first month this is less expensive
than traditional therapy
and you're worth it betterhelp.com
deloney take care of yourself start
today
all right let's go to kyle in los
angeles
kyle respect my authority what's up dude
how we doing
hey i'm doing great i just got to talk
to kelly daniel and now
dr john deloney today and it's not even
7 30 a.m so i'm having a great day
already
hey listen i got to talk to kelly this
morning and my day got better too so i
absolutely know what you're experiencing
trust me after a few minutes with me we
will bring you back down
to just regular old
so what's up man so my question
was how do you create and nurture a ride
or die group of friends who hold you
accountable
um my wife that's a good question man
thank you and my wife and i have been
listening to your show since the first
episode
i we hear you and dave talk about that
all the time
yeah um so i feel like i'm kind of 80
there like i have plenty of friends who
i talk to frequently
sometimes about tough things but it just
feels like i'm like just a little bit
away from really having kind of my
picture of a group
who might hold me accountable and call
me out when i'm violating my values
and i want to be that kind of friend for
other people and i guess i'm just not
sure how to get that last step or if i'm
overthinking this
or um you know what i can do
man yeah so hey um
talking to your phone okay but i'm gonna
i'm gonna recap it
and let me know if i'm right on so
you want to know how to create ride or
dive friends and you've heard me talking
about and
by the way big shout out to you and your
wife for being the first
two or three listeners that hung on for
the first 100 or so episodes that's
pretty rad
um but i talk a lot about
having a good crew that is with you that
will hold you accountable that will
laugh with you that will cry with you
pick you up when things when you fall
down and so you're wondering how to
cultivate that and you've got a group of
friends that you think are 80 percent
there but they just don't feel like they
got that last 20
what do you think that last 20 is what
does that feel like to you
yeah so i think to me it's like
if they see me you know they they can
speak into my life like if they see me
doing something that
might be against my values or their
values if they
kind of feel empowered to speak up and
that they
will do that or hold me accountable do
they do that now
i don't think so okay have you ever
given them permission to do that
or have you ever said hey call me out on
this
no i don't think i have
ta-da hey so
um whenever i talk about
ride or die guys here's in men and women
i got both in my life
usually it comes from two places number
one mutually shared experiences
where we have been through crap together
co-workers and all of a sudden the boss
quits or fires a bunch of people or
suddenly passes away or there's a car
wreck and
everybody's gotta just rise to that
occasion so you can't really plan those
things they happen
and then you look around and the smoke
clears and you realize i got a
group that's walking alongside me in
this deal the other
so you got mutually shared experiences
that's why a lot of people
stay connected to their childhood
friends forever or they stay
really connected their college friends
because everybody got picked up
and from their homes everyone they knew
and loved or everyone they hated and
whatever and they got dropped in a box
in a dorm they all shared a bathroom
together
you just gotta figure it out right or
that's why military bodies stay together
for years and years and years
or police officers or firemen ems they
have these shared experiences man
and it is like they've literally had to
ride or die together
and so shared experience is one
those get harder as you get older right
that's why you end up being just friends
with
like little league dads or
you know you sit by the same people in a
lawn chair next to a soccer game
you become friends with them that
becomes your shared experience which is
really a watered down watching
fifth graders run around on a soccer
field as a water dad it's not really a
shared experience but it kind of is
right
um the other one is intentionality
i am choosing to because of my season of
life to develop a
set of friends and i'm gonna
intentionally go first and put some
things out there
so here's a couple of things the way i
would um
when i talk about those here's some guys
in my life here's some ways that's
happened
i got a group of guys that we used to
hang out with when i was at one
university
several universities ago a couple of
those guys are still i talk to on a
weekly basis if not more frequent um
i remember i just moved to town and they
invited me and we were hanging out doing
something and i made some crack my wife
had to move six months later she was
finishing her dissertation she had to
move six months later
and so i was by myself in this new town
alone and i made some
joke about um total joke about
um dating while i waited for her to come
there's some just stupid pop off
whatever and my buddy who's one of my
best buddies now
looked at me and said hey we don't know
you that well you don't know us
so just so we were clear if you ever
cheat on your wife you better hope to
god she finds you before we do
and they all just smiled at me and i
remember going
whoa okay you know what i mean it
and so what i'm telling you it was a
highly intentional
these were friends these were guys being
silly they knew i was kidding i was
i mean good god i was totally kidding
but just in case there was any
any thing that wasn't clear here's where
we stand on that does that make sense
and so there was it was highly
intentional and then we ended up having
some shared experiences
and we were intentional about meeting
every week we were intentional about
being around each other's kids we were
intentional about doing fun things once
a month you know we all watch the fights
together whatever
and then we had shared experiences on
the back of that eventually somebody's
house catches on fire
eventually somebody needs help doing
something in their yard so we have these
shared experiences together
another one is me and some of my oldest
friends in the world
we've all been married for a long time
and we all have we all know me and
and john and todd we all know man if
if y'alls ever get crossways with your
wives i don't care who's at fault or why
she gets to stay with us and so everyone
knows that's kind of the rule
even if my wife cheated on me and
she i'm she would be okay at their house
them them letting me know me letting
them know i'm not gonna go to war i'm
not to pick sides here
because i love both of you and we'll
walk alongside you guys and whatever
happens and so
it becomes this outspoken thing
we were intentional about saying hey
here's what our values are also
i will tell them hey i'm starting a new
workout program and they are
love to catch me grabbing a donut in the
middle of a workout program they love it
right and they
oh man they will call me out and vice
versa
i'm thinking about losing weight you're
clearly not because you just ordered
double barbecue whatever that's that's
part of
being friends and part of being
connected there but it comes with
intentionality
and so i'd ask you man go first
go first does that make you nervous or
uncomfortable to do that kyle
it makes me a little bit nervous but i
think not too nervous to actually do it
okay i would love to see if you got some
friends that you think are 80
there that to me is one million percent
worth
worth the risk what do you gotta lose
because hey if they're not those guys
quit wasting your time man waste your
time
if they are call them together and say
hey i'm gonna start working on these two
things in my life
whatever it is i'm gonna start lifting
weights i'm gonna start i'm going to
start going on date nights with my wife
i want to be a better husband whatever
you want to do
start pick pick a couple of things and
then call them together and say
i want you all to call me out on this
stuff i trust you guys
i need some accountability i don't trust
myself all the time
i want you all to set up some to help me
with my boundaries
my gut tells me dude they will be all in
and you can tell them y'all can make fun
of me
you can laugh at me you can email me
text me oh
give them the boundaries and then ask is
there anything i can help you guys with
and they may say no you weirdo this
whole thing is weird why are you
inviting us into this
ugh gross let's just play pokemon or
whatever you guys are doing
and let's just go back to fortnite and
quit speaking um
my gut tells me they're gonna be jazzed
for real
does that sound cool yes i think
i i think they will be happy actually
okay so here's
here's the plan kyle i want you to do
this i want you to
don't be all weird and dramatic about it
don't send them like notes
and say hey guy friends um this weekend
i want to have a talk about our values
and accountability don't do that because
that'd make you weird but y'all go out
go watch the fights this weekend or you
all go hey
i don't know what y'all do like i'm just
dragging you into my world
um you all get together and go do
something and then say hey listen here's
two things i'm gonna work on
do that i want you to write me back and
let me know how that conversation goes
if i if i totally just blew it for you
um then i will commiserate with you and
i will announce to
all 106 listeners that i screwed up
um my gut tells me they're gonna be all
in
and they're gonna be jazzed about it and
then you're gonna have to be able to
accept the accountability when they
start making fun of your eating choices
or your workout choices
or how you're not being as good a
husband as you probably should be
and so on and so on and so on and so on
invite your wife to do the same thing
in a relationship if you're ever stuck
marriage
parenting friendship go first
go first what are you waiting for what
are you waiting for go first you're
gonna find out that that
those relationships weren't with what
you thought or
you're gonna be the first person to
extend the hand and start healing that
thing but go first
got nothing to lose man you got nothing
to lose and everything in the game
awesome question kyle thank you so much
and i think she'll let me talk about my
two two or three four guys i love kyle i
mean uh
kevin and michael and john and todd i
love it man it's awesome
all right as we wrap up today's show
dude
we're gonna go straight into the romance
straight into the romance
sometimes when i say this song out loud
i just get all teary james
kelly it's in my heart
off the 1987 slippery wet album bon jovi
kelly threw him up i'll throw him up
with you
the john bonds says this as i sit in the
smoky room the night about to end and i
pass my time with strangers
this bottle's my only friend remember
when we used to park on butler street
out in the dark remember we lost the
keys
and you lost more than that in my back
seat she lost her jacket and her
baseball cards and her lunch and stuff
remember how we used to talk about
busting out would break their hearts
together forever
never say goodbye never say goodbye you
and me and my old friends hoping it
would never end
never say goodbye holding on to never
say goodbye
on the dr john delaney show